you think they got a foul kevin durant
goes to the rim and flushes it down
i don't think anyone fully was aware
that they needed to come up and foul or
they were just slow in keeping up with
the ball movement by the nets but
nonetheless collins was looking to do it
the rant goes quick
some breathing room for the nets after
uh action
durance oh wow the tarantula you know
they're gonna start relying on the jump
shot but kd is like
forget that
i'm going back to what i was if not
better than what i was and plays like
this
back here rachel is drumming misses
rat comes the other way
durant crossover and the slab kevin
durant
bob's happy now let's go up by two
by high percentage how about kevin
durant to cross over and tells audrey
drummond find your business
mama enjoying her son cheesy rice and
all
11 second difference shot clock to game
clock
dotson loses it walking the tightrope
oh blake griffin razzle dazzle oh
next level
kevin durant the rack attack
and one of the highlights of the year
of the year
in the regular season finale
razzle dazzle flavor and bring in the
spice
[Applause]
oh
this is just too good
astonishing
the bop
the power
oh oh get ready
play-offs are coming
it's a one-point game
let's find themselves
in another potentially hairy situation
harden goes long green ball fake layup
is good and a foul
with 5.5
harden throws the touchdown pass to jeff
green
talk about redemption
brooklyn in the same position they were
in
two nights ago
jeff green wide open and it looked like
he didn't even really want to shoot that
right there but
knocks down the layup great pass by
hardin another assist from him
[Music]
hard enough bruce brown screen behind
the back to bruce brown
highlight factory james harden
the nets force the turnover harden oh
what a bounce for green
james harden
he's at another level
this is just absolutely filthy
through four players
right in stride
the eyes
the overhead
look at that i mean
james harden makes it look too easy in
this seventh and final game here's
durant
for heart
one on the shot clock hardin fires away
[Applause]
and just great defense on that
possession by milwaukee
and harden bailing him out calling glass